kalila George look at me all that just
told me this week and I can't believe
you never even mentioned it oh that's
what I was gonna yeah that you you got
mocked oh yeah
no I went to Columbia a couple weeks
Eero last week yeah you got mugged oh
don't forget he got drugged then he got
I woke up in his own piss you know I'm
like I've got four days here in Columbia
I gotta live it up my first day there
see a few sights see what going just to
go right yeah no I haven't been to
heaven Columbia and for I never heard of
Hawaii Hawaii well you know my like put
it my friends getting married and in
Spain and like August so I was so I was
looking up cheap flights to go to Spain
the other side of the world is awesome
though it really is like becoming such a
huge tourist hub yeah based on Georgia
story yeah yeah yeah I mean he made some
really Victoria yeah okay so I'm like I
got four days here I gotta live it up so
I should see a few museums been like
first night yeah Gilbert so I like I'm
going out I go like bar hopping I don't
meet it I mean if met a few people like
during the day but you you think you're
gonna get [ __ ] South America make sure
he sent out look at my eyes right now
globally globally your unfuckable
alright that's even in LA stellar maybe
even hold on it no [ __ ] for you okay so
South America I'm exotic
I'm Jan yeah what year is the you you
arrived at what day Thursday yeah okay
this is the the text that we received
from George that Thursday just grabbing
a coffee and girls want to take a photo
with me here look at it and that's a
last we heard from him just grabbing a
coffee and girls want to take a photo
with me that's so [ __ ] wrong he said
that's a Gilbert and I am [ __ ] to can
let me look at these girls though let me
look at them thank you they're okay yeah
yeah they're okay what did they say to
you like they do the whole Brad Pitt
thing again no no it's no Brad Pitt was
just like hey can we take a photo what
you
yeah uh if you have if you don't know
listening when he goes to other
countries people think that he's Brad
Pitt well allegedly it happened once
okay yeah well that person yeah is blind
and [ __ ] they have those two in
India anyone looks at you goes is that
Brad Pitt blind of [ __ ] yeah no I'm
not a doctor or I would just go that's
what you are have you okay I have black
friends who have been - who are actually
in Korea right now yeah and my friend's
boyfriend who's a black guy everyone
everyone was screaming and taking
pictures with him because they thought
he was a sure he looks nothing like
Usher
yeah nothing so I believe Georgia story
it's just sometimes you know yeah if
they've never seen anything that pink
before they're probably just gonna
assume it's Brad Pitt so what you're
saying to me if I go to Africa yeah I'm
in the Congo they're gonna go gently yes
possibly Faberge egg body people in
Africa like start like praising Bobby
did you just call me a Faberge egg body
and we got the title of this episode
brought to you - you just said that
earlier today using video games and he
had his underwear hiked up really high
and his shirt tucked in his underwear he
stood up I swear to you that you know
there's two types of body shapes they
they always say your pair your Apple
shape there's a third he's a fancy
Faberge your fancy fancy yeah and she
[ __ ] me where's the joke the joke's on
her you be [ __ ] Faberge your [ __ ]
if I ever see eggs i I've always been a
fan of Faberge they always wanted to own
one yeah so anyways - tell me what
happens yeah so I go out I go
bar-hopping didn't mean anybody like
that and then I'm walking down the
street and this real nice guy Javier
comes off okay has he said his name yeah
not his real name did he see you many
was having orgies made that up and for
the story be real no whose real name is
Javier I believe you know the real game
there in this story just listen alright
so how we are so we go out I buy him a
beer like a bar
he was a nice guy he was like how-to he
had an easy laugh like a her everything
I said what did have yer say he did for
a living George oh he's an aspiring
rapper we talked about like China
meeting a Chinese going guy going I
Drive for NASCAR yeah same thing nope no
you do not say no you don't hae the
Asian guy just won that huge racecar
thing in Asia you know the name of it
previously made a comment yeah so he
kept on like being like oh man let's go
let's go to this strip club and I'm like
man look at me I don't need to go to a
strip club here honey I'm exotic here
you know like that's why I came here so
I said yeah I can be and like you know
he's like yeah let's go to the strip
club
he's like I'm like nah then he's like oh
man I know this great club down the way
so let's uh and I'm like sure I can go
there maybe learn some salsa have some
fun so we start walking it's we're
getting to this kind of kind of see to
your section town but I'm like I trust
this guy he's a he's an aspiring rapper
he knows his way around town George so
we get source two of the Troy's your
strip club we get there I'm like oh of
course it's a strip club after you say
like no three times in a latin-american
country you're gonna be at a strip club
so we get in and I'm like okay I'll I'll
stay here for a few drinks since we
bought a bottle of rum on the way and I
had two drinks two shots of the rum and
then I woke up in my hotel bed the next
morning with my pants on I was like this
is kind of strange and then I kind of
felt down I was like I think I peed my
pants and then I checked my pockets I'm
like I have nothing in my pockets I got
drugged and robbed in Colombia what my
mom like what scared would happen
happened
what everybody assumes is gonna happen
I've been all around South America
completely he was drugged obviously okay
so I'm just gonna tell you something
right now okay
from the time from the strip club till
you woke up in that seven hour period
anything could have happened I told them
oh so could you check your butthole how
did it feel
was it throbbing you could have had
midgets I had a great likes night's
sleep that's the most had you go to a
foreign country for a story I don't even
remember the [ __ ] story yeah I'm so
mad at you right now I am a little mad
at you Jordan
what'd he take um I have no idea I had a
great night's sleep no what do you take
on your pockets so we got my my iPhone
and about a hundred fifty bucks
Craig Lords one credit card I had two so
I kept them all separate my cash
separate had my passport separate so I
always split up everything I was mugged
in South Africa I told ya so I know how
it feels
but that wasn't like it was obvious yeah
I wasn't drunk no I was it was purely
because like there were warning signs at
every step and I just walked right past
every warning sign I was like born in a
new country and I wanted to like number
one Xavier that's all you made the
mistake number two is spying rapper
aspiring rapper second mistake you have
to realize you look a certain way you
look mommy well I do think like my
because I asked the lady I last the the
lady at the hotel yes she has to unlock
the door cuz it's like a dangerous area
yeah so I was like hey dude did I seem
strange last night when I came back just
like no you uh you said goodbye to your
friend you hugged him and then you like
walked up to your room that's that's an
inside job I say it's an inch said she
knew about it she knows Javier everyone
in the strip club - yeah they do this
off they do it off they they wait
outside the hotel not the hotel lady
butthole [ __ ] I think motel lady though
than my hotel was so hard for me to
believe that as blacked-out as you were
that it let's say you got drugged with
you know GHB or
thing like that that you were lively and
conversational and seemed fine that
seemed so unlikely for me like you only
took two shots of rum and let's say you
were remember yeah yeah but I woke up
yeah I didn't have a hangover anything I
don't know we never heard from him again
so you took your phone - right so after
he sent us that picture I was like
George doesn't posted anything from
Columbia okay stop stop
so when that happens what are you
Verizon AT&T you're 80 they don't have
those stores there what do you mean if
you find my phone you mean no they don't
have an AT&T in Colombia likes it yeah
do they have those are yeah I didn't
know luckily that I know where they have
AT&T Hawaii you piece of [ __ ] this is
why this is where we always argue the
farthest place he wants to travel as a
couple is Hawaii
yeah why their water slices with a
little like fruits fire sticks yeah I
love all that [ __ ] yeah well then you
know what babe I don't know what else to
say it's an I don't I don't want to end
up like him yeah also you know mostly
you can go to Columbia not end up like
George I'm sorry you also go to Columbia
and get shot up by cartels yeah that's
true come on no I've researched it
beforehand you know used to be a lot of
kidnappings now it's down to like 200
years so it's a lot say that's actually
very low also you see the 200 I'm that
guy you're part of that now I have a
part of the 200 and I'm gonna be the one
that's gonna be like the new thing yeah
they cut his ass cheeks off for no
reason new guy that does that
experimental yeah you wouldn't stick out
there are a lot of Asians in South
America so I decided I wanted like I was
like okay this is my experience here I'm
gonna do the full experience I'm gonna
report it to the police
yeah so I went in and that was of course
I walked in like you know my pants had
dried luckily I only had one pair of
pants the whole frickin trip also I
don't think you peed yourself I think
they peed on you maybe they just peed on
you dude you know we don't with pee
though cuz I was at my crotch what do
you mean like you reached that like it
into the circle oh my god dr. pepper
Mountain Dew it wasn't sticky it maybe
you came from the euphoria that I had a
great time my friend it was really wet I
just want to say to this demand I would
I would have went right home let me tell
ya I woke up the next morning I was like
I'm gonna continue with my plans I hiked
up mon-star out there this beautiful
mountain oh they'll what say it again
like it's out there that's just
beautiful mountain looks like on the
side of the what is it well it's like a
religious hike there's something at the
top that place yeah I got robbed again
up oh it scared us shut the hole like
every time I walk around any [ __ ] no no
at that point you don't you're not you
just want to it doesn't matter at one
point with this guy yeah I will go to
the Grand Y in the hotel they have the
number two spot in the world
it's fast good yeah they have a papaya
like steam room thing it's like no it's
not papaya papaya its papaya hot tub I
mean and in its incident water it's
papaya juice so you can you go in there
and you put a little cucumbers in your
eyes and you just pass out it's the best
oh [ __ ] no [ __ ] mugging no urine on
myself
nothing no you're
[Music]